Welcome to PyMOL 101 with Molecular Memory!
In this lesson, we’ll learn about the different
PyMOL input and output file types, and how
to export a publication quality image.
In the last part, we’ll learn to work with
scenes, one of the best ways to save work
and time.
Let’s go!
We’ll start in the RCSB PDB with the structure
of carbonic anhydrase from the previous lesson,
PDB ID 3UYN.
Given the beautiful, complex looking structures
we’ve seen in the first two lessons, you
might be surprised to learn that the input
file type is simply a text file.
The original files were dot PDB, but a new
file type called CIF has replaced that.
The details of how these files differ is important
to a structural biologist, but a little beyond
my scope.
If you’re interested in these nuances though,
check out the video description for a link
to this PDB-101 page explaining them.
From the RCSB PDB page, let’s view the CIF
file for the structure.
We’ve got some general information about
the citation first, some structural information
that PyMOL reads to set up the cartoon renderings,
and near the end, the file gives information
about the 3D coordinates of each atom in every
residue of the structure.
That’s all PyMOL needs to create great images.
We’re going to use the file we saved in
Lesson 2.
If you didn’t work through that episode,
pause this video, go to the video description,
and copy the command line code at the end.
Paste that into the command line, press enter,
and you’ll be all caught up!
Now save using the dropdown file menu, or
by pressing control S on your keyboard.
This saves a PyMOL session file, with a dot
PSE at the end of the file name.
PSE files open in PyMOL and can be shared
with others helping you create images.
Speaking of images, PyMOL exports PNG image
files.
To prep this structure for a publication quality
image, we’ll first change the background.
In the dropdown menu: Display, background,
white.
The color white is preferred because manuscripts
have a white background, and the image appears
to float against it.
Black backgrounds also take a lot of printer
ink, so back in the day when we printed everything
it was very important to avoid black.
This next part is tricky.
Reposition the image and try to show each
and every active site side chain clearly.
We don’t want any hidden behind anything
else, and we want to avoid an edge on view,
like how we can’t see this tryptophan side
chain here clearly.
The clipping we learned about in Lesson 1
can be helpful.
Scroll two fingers up and down on the trackpad
to adjust, or use the scroll wheel on a mouse.
Cut off cartoon renderings look pretty bad
too, so this part takes time to get just right.
Ok, I think this is the best I can do with
this structure.
Now it’s time to save the PNG.
We can use the file menu, export image as,
PNG, and I get some options to choose from.
But the way I normally save is using the external
GUI buttons at the top right.
Click Dray/Ray and you can adjust the PNG
to be as small or as large as you need.
If you have the option to ray, this will add
a transparent background and make a very sharp
image.
It gives some additional depth, and makes
it look like there’s a light shining on
the structure.
This creates shadows, like we see right here,
which may not be preferred since there’s,
well, actually no spotlight within a cell.
Whether you chose to draw or ray here, you’ll
get the option to save the PNG or copy the
image directly to the clipboard, which I find
very useful.
Not to be dramatic, but the day I learned
to save scenes revolutionized my PyMOL modeling
experience.
It is so easy to mis-click and mess up your
structure, and scenes give you a quick and
easy way to go back.
Every time I like the way the structure looks
while I’m modeling, I save a scene.
Go to the dropdown SCENE menu, store, select
F1.
The scene appears in the bottom left of the
structure viewer window.
Right click and “rename” to give your
scene a more memorable name.
The old scene name appears in the upper left-hand
side of the structure viewer window.
Delete that, and let’s call this “active_site”.
If you make a small adjustment to the structure
and you want to update the active site scene,
right click and choose “update”.
Let’s change the whole rendering to see
how scenes work.
Next to 3UYN in the names panel: Action button,
A, zoom.
This zooms out to show the entire protein.
Now, S button.
Show as, surface.
Rotate the protein and reorient it a little
bit.
Let’s color it a solid color.
Now, save a scene.
Scene dropdown, store, F1.
Right-click on F1 to rename it to surface,
or whatever you want.
Now, left click on the two scene names to
toggle between them.
Neat!
You can always return to the exact view from
any scene you’ve saved.
Don’t forget to control S now and save your
whole PSE session file with the new scenes
in it.
Thanks for watching this episode of PyMOL
101.
Feel free to leave me a comment or a question,
and if you’re enjoying this series, subscribe
to my channel.
Happy modeling!